well there's something else that I
thought was kind of cool that you're
doing so you have it's a new line at
Walmart right a new clothing line yeah
brand I know you know it's funny I was
um when I was at home I drove by the
Walmart that my mom and I had to like
walk to because my mom's car didn't work
oh and you know and it was super far I
mean it felt like 10 miles I think
there's only four but regardless I was
like oh my gosh I have this partnership
with a brand that I've been you know
literally shopping at forever yeah when
I was a young kid watch every little
girl like they didn't have cute clothes
like there weren't cute girl clothes for
chubby girls or for any anybody that was
sort of outside of a straight size just
generally and now that they are
incorporating such incredible it's like
affordable but it's also trendy and I
think that's really important giving
people new feel then we may do good and
all of that it's all sort of
encompassing and so when I you know was
even approached by my mom and I was like
oh well yeah like this makes sense for
me because it's something that I think
is just um I think it's real that's what
I like it's believable it's like girl I
shot there too growing up and it's I
think you know for some people they hear
like oh well you don't need to be trendy
like that's not important it's like you
don't realize how important that is
unless you don't fit in that circle you
don't realize how devastating that is
for a kid to like you know even me I
grew up you know with payless shoes and
everybody else had Nikes and it was like
my shoes are the ones that made black
marks all over the basketball court and
it's and those kind of things
counts and that really does you know you
start recognizing your life and your
being is like less than and I think that
it's really important and awesome that
they reached out to you because you
represent a lot of the American
community and the world community and so
I think it's really important that when
you when any of us do like these sponsor
things or these endorsements or these
deals that it's believable and it's real
and that's what I really loved about it
so thank you for doing it it's cool I'm
super grateful and it's it's funny how
the life happens and how it hold and I'm
like oh I would I would never thought
you know a girl struggling in games
before I would
you know have sort of a really important
partnership with ya and an end can
create such an impact for other little
girls in Gainesville that are going
through the same thing so I think that's
the coolest thing we're able to do with
whatever you want to call this our
little version of superpowers so
subscribe to my channel subscribe to my
channel subscribe to my channel
subscribe to my channel please don't
make me keep going